from the daily mail exclusive is this
the proof that ilhan omar married her
own brother to bypass u.s immigration
rules conservative group's dna test from
congresswoman cigarette butt purports to
show 99.99
match to her second husband ahmed elmi
and so they show this photo of villanoma
smoking a cigarette and i guess that's
supposed like supposed to be proof that
big tent republican pak i guess
secured the cigarette after the fact and
then did a dna test on it and then you
end up with this dna siblingship report
which is claiming what do they say it's
like a 99
okay they say the result of the test
assert that there is a 99 point oh man
i'm gonna read this nine nine nine nine
nine eight percent chance that omar and
her second husband ahmed elmi are
siblings the report drawn up by endeavor
dna laboratories does not name either
omar or elmi instead referring to them
as sibling one and sibling two
it says that sibling one sample was
garnered from a cigarette butt and and
sibling two is from a drinking straw
you know what's really funny is that we
talked about this like a year or so ago
where it was like we were joking because
there's an episode of law and order
where like they're trying to bust this
guy and they can't get the evidence and
then he drinks from a coffee and then
throws the cup in the dumpster or like
into a trash and they walk up and pick
it up with like tongs and they're like
discarded materials and they're like hey
you can't do that and then they get the
dna evidence and i was like what if
somebody just like found an old snot rag
and then randy and i improved it
i'm not sure i believe
you know people went out and actually
did this i'm not i think it's kind of
outlandish i don't know what else
someone would do like if you're trying
to prove this but i'll tell you where it
gets really really crazy here's what
they say
the test was posted online by anton
lazzaro a republican strategist in
minneapolis on wednesday around 12 hours
later lazzaro was arrested on federal
child trafficking charges or i'm sorry
isn't it isn't a child
i'm being careful because it's youtube
trafficking but they they did say under
18 uh was was part of it so it's trap
yeah okay it does say child right child
trafficking people under 18. he's
currently he is now in custody awaiting
a hearing on monday
i wonder how many people are screaming
it's a conspiracy
he was about to bust ellen omar or maybe
he's a shady guy and he does shady
things and this is
complete bs evidence
i guess outside of any of these dna
claims there's circumstantial evidence
that leads many people to believe she
married her brother because it was it
was to get him in the country right yeah
it was an immigration thing and then he
got to go to school and so you have
multiple layers of potential fraud in
terms of the immigration fraud the
student loan fraud and probably other
misrepresentation
as well and the circumstantial evidence
is
very compelling here let's jump to that
but first i want to show people listen i
am i am not saying i know anything
definitively i'm saying people have made
these assertions there have been bits of
circumstantial evidence to the point
that star tribune a pulitzer
prize-winning paper reported in june 20
on june 23 2019
new documents revisit questions about
rep ilhan omar's marriage history
although she has legally corrected the
discrepancy she has declined to say
anything about how or why it happened
they say
new investigative documents released by
a state agency have given fresh life to
lingering questions about the marital
history of rep ilhan omar and whether
she once married a man possibly her own
brother to skirt immigration laws now if
if there was
i'll say this either star tribune is
extremely reckless
by saying it was possibly her brother
or there is circumstantial evidence many
people have seen which say
yeah that might have been a brother
right and also the star tribune is
sort of the house democrat party paper
in the area they were very favorable
towards illinois the whole way i mean
she was like the perfect progressive
uh sort of avatar for minneapolis
so yeah you go in you can look at the
marriage certificate you can look at the
addresses that she was living in with
the alleged brother husband at the same
time her actual
husband was living in like the same
place you know you can run through all
of these different threads
two things jump out at me though and one
of the reasons i wrote this book is
because
the brother husband thing was like the
least of the potential issues that i saw
in her i said if you actually look at
her on the merits the regressive
ideology that she harbors the fact that
she was sitting on the house foreign
affairs committee which he still sits on
and if you apply the russian collusion
standard or any collusion standard her
lynx ties coordination with foreign
adversaries
what i found and sort of the starting
point for the book was
she has ties to erdogan in turkey
substantial ties when she was a state
legislator she had a meeting with
erdogan on the sideline of u.n general
assembly what state legislator from
minnesota as a remember when she said uh
we should sanction israel because of
human right abuses but then said
sanctioning turkey would be a human
rights abuse a lot of people were like
hey does she speak the language turkish
she doesn't i don't believe she speaks
the language but she is featured in
turkish state media all the time she's
had meetings with several dignitaries
from turkey always taking a pro turkish
fund turkey has relations with close
relations with somalia so i do think
that that is a part of this as well that
she is pro-turkish in large part because
of that
and that's not even to get into like all
of the domestic islamist groups and
individuals you know and the
anti-semitism so oh yeah that we didn't
even get to that yeah right right so
this is what what bugs me about this is
this is a
a problem with the democratic party at
large ilhan omar did what i would refer
to as crop dusting anti-semitism you
know like crop master planes get like
real close to the ground they don't
touch it
so she was saying like you know she said
it's all about the benjamins
she said you know multiple like dual
loyalties and stuff like that and those
are typically more more aggressive those
tropes are used more aggressively and
direct anti-semitic attacks so she
didn't directly make it about being
jewish but she you know she crop dusted
the ideas and it got a lot of people
angry and instead of doing anything
about it the multiple things more than
just you know that a lot of people think
she was overtly anti-semitic they just
say we're going to denounce all forms of
bigotry and she's allowed to keep her
positions and do whatever she wants the
republicans would set their own on fire
in two seconds like they've done with
marjorie taylor greene it was uh was it
steve king i think he made that tweet
about white nationalism they kicked him
out immediately and lost his primary
because republicans are like we don't
want none of that the democrats though
they're like who cares you know when
i'll tell you this it's because of the
media
because and that's there's another thing
here's why republicans care more about
the opinion of the new york times than
the opinion of their constituents
because the republicans know if they if
they fart it'll be the headline paper on
the new york times and the democrats
know they can do and say basically
anything and the papers will not cover
you got aoc being able to tweet tweet it
out and it's more popular than the new
york times like she has six million
followers i think no no she has like 12
or 13 12 million followers on twitter
alone part of the thesis of the book was
that
the closing ranks around omar to go from
explicitly condemning omar and her
remarks too we're going to explicitly
condemn bigotry of any kind that anyone
has ever said and not name her in the
house resolution or resolutions around
it that was the turning point which
showed you that the democrat party is
all in and embracing the regressive
progressives because either they think
that that's where the party is going and
that's where the power is or the part is
already there and i was writing this a
couple years ago and they're there i
would say right now the other thing
worth noting just on the media point
briefly tangentially is why is it always
that it's just the daily mail that
reports on hunter biden and ill on omar
notice how there are no domestic
publications that ever delve into any of
these things i mean with rare exceptions
as you know the new york post obviously
100 biden but that said why do you have
to go to the daily mail to get your news
about ilhan omar isn't that kind of
strange yeah you know what's fascinating
too is uh
daily mail's not bad uh the left hates
them and they're always acting like it's
it's fake news or whatever but they
typically have some of the most
comprehensive breakdowns of news stories
you'll find they have four or five
thousand words on a single story that
the hill will have 300 on and then and
then they'll attach you know related
stories with like background information
i'm i'm i'm rather impressed by that
it's a british company
yeah it's murdock too right i think so
and and they had people on the ground
for ill and omar there were like three
journalists in the country maybe who
were looking at her and they were dogged
in covering the omar beat i was a big
fan of al jazeera getting my middle east
uh news because i would read a lot of
american propaganda and then i'd go and
read al jazeera and see like oh there's
a lot more going on than what i'm
getting fed by the american media
mainstream media is um what's what i'm
thinking of um refuse
debris debris flotsam
most of it well there's lots of bits of
gold in the in the sewage and you're
like how do i get it out but it's so
effective though the hysteria i'm sure
we'll talk about the coronavirus stuff
but the oh yeah
hysteria engendered around it where we
were talking before the show that it's
sort of like in 9 11 after 9 11 people
watching the tv every day and i remember
that i was a kid and and i remember
being glued to it every day and you can
see how people get whipped up to the
point where we're talking about
potentially mandating
an experimental use drug whatever you
think about it and you might think it's
the greatest thing in the world or you
might be skeptical of it
mandating
at the point of a government gun
figuratively
injecting yourself with an emergency use
anything that hasn't been tested over a
long period of time and that's just
normal in 2021 america well the worrying
thing about that is just
mandating something that a doctor could
say you can't get
you like you you go to your doctor and
the doctor says i recommend no because
you have underlying medical conditions
and now what now you can't go to the
movies anymore apparently me san
francisco and new orleans in new york i
think one of the city
so yeah i mean it's been it's been uh
you know what it is though it's not
necessarily the media it is but there's
another component it is the
tribal cult like mentality these people
have it's authoritarianism right it's
this strict adherence to the collective
and so if the mass says so they will
just do it they will that they want it
and they have their brown shirts right
so it's like with with you know mayo
gate we're calling it they they will
they know that it's sarcastic terrorism
i guess that's what they call it right
they like to accuse the right of doing
it and the idea is that trump would come
out and say something like oh won't
someone rid me of this priest and then
someone would go do it he never directed
him to do it the idea is that if you say
a bunch of things enough people will
just take action so you don't overtly
tell people to do it in this instance
this is exactly what's happening with
with the left they'll come out and say
look at this restaurant they're liars
they're evil they they're they're far
right because they know
someone will then go attack them and
i've heard so many stories like this
from conservatives where they're like
they'll get a smear piece next thing
another their phone's ringing off the
hook they're they're getting kicked off
social media they've got people showing
up at their houses this has been going
on for some time and i'll tell you it's
like it's like the rules for radicals
man they accuse the republicans and the
right and the anti-establishment of
doing exactly what they do they they
project that because it's an effective
offense then when you come back and
there's like a regular person not paying
attention you say look look what they're
doing they'll be like they said you were
doing that first
and so then they just they get away with
that tendency to believe the first thing
you hear if you hear a bunch of
information it's a lot of times it's the
first one you hear that's like codes the
mind you know the mental pathways and
then there it is also no one sees the
correction they always see the story
that gets spun out and then repeated a
trillion times
and the lie told a trillion times before
you get to the truth well what's gonna
win i'll i'll give you a really good
example of how this manifests in real
life um
whoever calls the police first tends to
win
so if ian and i get into a fight
and then i call the police
i say tends to because it doesn't always
work that way and then i say hey i need
help this guy did this when the cops
show up and then i give a statement i'm
the one who called i have the benefit of
the doubt there's actually a con artist
exploit this well what you do is
i don't i don't want to get into the
full tricks i think we've talked about
it before but con artists will do a
trick where they will call the police on
you and then get the cops to rob you for
them because you called the cops the
cops will typically so there's some
information gathering you need first
there are some tricks which i'm not
going to explain so i don't want anyone
to go and do this but yes one of a very
common hustle
is to call the police on somebody the
cops will then search the person and
then give over their possessions to you
yeah yep yep whoever calls the cops
first wins i've been i've been i've had
this i've personally experienced
situations like this
where i've been the victim of a crime
but they
turned my phone off and then called the
police on me and then the cops came and
arrested appeal to authority is that an
argument tactic
the cops tell me like what are we
supposed to do every time we show up
arrest both people and i'm like i called
the cops first but they turned my phone
off they took my phone they hung up on
it they canceled it and then they called
and the cops came arrested there's an
element of that in the media that's the
thing right so the democrats will be
like the republicans are extremist
terrorists then antifa goes around
smashing and destroying everything and
they say well it's self-defense because
the republicans are terrorists
also i mean
leftist ideology has lent itself
historically to being
violent and at the point of a gun
imposing your belief because if there's
coercion that's necessarily built into
it if you won't go along we're gonna
have to make you go along and it's for
your own good also by the way i mean
who's ever heard of limited government
live and with people having bloody
anti-cultural revolutions has that ever
existed in the history of mankind i
don't think exactly i like to use some
of these analogies you know why is it
that conservatives are more likely to
get banned on social media
uh if
if if i told you that uh dave rubin
would be rallying a bunch of you know
black-clad masked far-right extremists
to twitter hq and would be smashing out
windows and stuff would you believe it
no no of course not joke it's not gonna
but if i told you that uh uh you know
antifa some left-wing organizers were
gonna be showing up with molotovs and
crowbars twitter hq would you believe it
yeah of course so what do you think jack
dorsey thinks when he's got his finger
over the band button he's like i could
ban the right all day ain't gonna do
anything about it i'd ban one leftist
and they'll show up here with a brick
nah i don't want to deal with that plus
they're in the bay area so they're like
we the last thing we need is all these
people storming the camp just get rid of
the conservatives but not to mention
they're in the barrier they probably
agree with antifa to a great extent yeah
yeah there's also i feel like a little
bit of a self-loathing element to it too
like how do they reconcile their leftism
with their material success and like all
the trappings that they have there's
probably a deep-seated psychological not
that i have any expertise in this and
that maybe that'll get me banned
but but that said i do think that the
deep-seated narcissistic psychological
part of it is probably
uh discounted to an extent it shouldn't
be thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time